[Musique]
une place vraiment dangereux vous
travaillez j'avais peur j'avais souvent
très peur j'ai commencé à réaliser que
éventuellement quelqu'un est blessé nous
avons parlé à trois anciens mineurs de
la mine dunkin à leur demande nous avons
masquer leur identité ils craignent des
représailles
les trois ont signé une entente avec
leur ancien employeur qui les oblige à
garder le silence
des fois il ya des grosses roches
grosses comme des pick up qui tombe à
côté nous le toit ça fais tout le temps
d'une expo les bombes ou longs pour
soutenir le plafond la question de la
sécurité précaire dans la mine est un
sujet connu dans cette communauté
mais tabou car ici les emplois sont
rares et tout le monde se connaît la
mine de nickel est ouverte depuis un an
elle est située sous terre près de glace
bay au cap-breton extraire du charbon
libère deux substances du méthane et de
la poussière
un mélange hautement explosif
ce qui fait du métier de mineur de
charbon un des emplois les plus
dangereux dans le monde et c'est pour ça
qu'il existe des normes de sécurité très
élevé des normes que les entreprises du
nouveau propriétaire de la mine chris
klein n'ont pas toujours respectée celui
qui a été qualifié de baron américain du
charbon est venu avec des promesses de
prospérité
la création éventuelle de 300 emplois
rêve non seulement pour un coin de pays
où être mineur de charbon fait partie de
l'adn depuis plus de 300 ans
mais le rêve surtout pour une communauté
où le marasme économique est une maladie
chronique
j'étais content quand ils ont annoncé
l'ouverture des mines ça des bonnes
nouvelles
ça voulait dire que je pouvais revenir
de l'ouest est avec ma famille
travaillait chez nous mais les choses
ont commencé à vraiment se gâter au mois
de novembre dernier
quarante neuf mineurs ont été licenciés
je persuadé d'avoir été congédié parce
que je disais aux patrons les façons de
faire cet impôt sécuritaire une façon de
faire bien connu du milliardaire selon
gary taille le licenciement de la
quarantaine d'employés avoir noël a été
fait pour créer un climat de peur et
d'intimidation parmi les employés la
compagnie a expliqué les licenciements
par des impératifs opérationnels et
l'achat de nouveaux équipements ou
qu'une mine de chris klein en amérique
du nord n'est syndiqué
nos trois mineurs nous raconte qu'il y
aurait eu des menaces pour empêcher une
accréditation syndicale une protection
dont ils auraient bien besoin
mon collègue était sûr et michel à près
de sept mètres de haut il portait pas
d'armé
on nous demandait d'aller vite et les
superviseurs sont floutés oncologue a
perdu connaissance
le superviseur ya même pas conseillé le
ivory médecins les pratiques cavalières
dans cette mine ne s'arrête pas là voilà
rose et les murs avec du béton c'est
super dangereux pour la santé de façon
quand on le fait faut porter un masque
pour protéger nos poumons mais aucun
superviseurs qui demandait aux jeunes de
porter leur masque les queues coupées
souvent de l'assisteur sans permis par
un extincteur ne fut pas détecteurs de
gaz
une seule est un certain progrès de te
répéter c'est l'équivalent de mettre des
humains directement dans un canon si
quelque chose ne tourne pas rond et que
la mine explose tout y passe et ça
ressemble à ce qui est arrivé il ya un
peu plus de 25 ans en nouvelle écosse le
9 mai 1992
la tragédie de la mine ouest aurait
emporté 26 hommes soit toute l'équipe en
service à cause d'une simple étincelle
le premier ministre à l'époque n'avait
rien vu venir au terme d'une commission
denquête les experts ont déterminé que
l'événement était prévisible et ils ont
condamné la manière négligente dont la
mine était exploité des gros bugs et l
avocat des survivants de la tragédie
doit suer à la lumière de nos
informations on comprend que peu de
choses ont changé
la tragédie de la mine ouest ray nous a
permis de réaliser qu'il n'y avait pas
de protection premier mineur et que
certains d'entre eux qui avaient soulevé
le problème ont été intimidés certains
qui ont osé parler se sont même fait
licencier la nouvelle écosse a fait 26
inspections depuis l'ouverture de la
mine en moins d'un an
l'entreprise a reçu soixante trois
avertissements et trente et une
ordonnance
une visite sur deux des inspecteurs de
la province est annoncée l'autre moitié
se fait à l'improviste
malgré ces inspections le ministre du
travail de la nouvelle écosse n'avait
jamais entendu parler des événements
dont nous lui avons fait part ni du
bilan en matière de respect des normes
et règlements de chris klein aux états
unis le directeur des inspecteurs me
tiens bien informée ce qui m'importe
avant tout c'est savoir le propriétaire
de la mine est un bon citoyen très
sensibles aux questions de sécurité et
selon les informations que je reçois
c'est le gac et ce dès le gouvernement a
ordonné une seule fois la fermeture de
la mine pendant quelques heures en mars
2017 en raison de problèmes de
ventilation
la direction de la mine a refusé notre
demande d'entrevue par courriel le vice
président affirme que l'entreprise a
comme priorité numéro un la sécurité de
ses employés
la productivité par bain avant la
sécurité
on est proche de ce qui s'est passé à
wall street où il y avait des façons de
faire très dangereuse pour une mine de
charbon où s'est plaint de gaz
productivité contre sécurité l'enjeu ne
date pas d'hier
les mineurs craignent que le sombre
passé des mines de charbon ne soit
encore bien présent